اكد قائد القوات الاوكرانيه في منطقه
عمليات تافريا جنوب شرق اوكرانيا تحقيق
تقدم على طول الجبهه التي تشمل جنوب مقاطع
تيزا بوروجيا ودونيتسك واعلن المسؤول
العسكري استهداف نحو 1800 هدف خلال يوم
واحد مما اسفر عن مقتل وجرح افراد من خمس
سرايا من الجيش الروسي وتدمير اكثر من 80
اليه عسكريه كما افادت القوات الاوكرانيه
بتحقيق اختراق لتحصينات الروسيه في
هذا هو اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه تدمير
احد مراكز صنع القرار التابعه للقوات
الاوكرانيه بضربه شنتها عبر البحر والجو
وقال المتحدث باسم الوزاره ان قوات بلاده
صدت 10 هجمات اوكرانيه في اتجاه دونيتسكو
وزابولوجيا كما اعلن حكام ومقاطعات
بيلبورود وبريانس وكورسك تعرضها لقصف
اوكراني من جهتها نشرت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه صورا قالت انها لتدمير احد معاقل
القوات الاوكرانيه جنوب